So the question is what you actually suppose we do?
Um, what realistically can be changed?
So what I'm gonna do is outline the 5 key asks, um,
for all of the rallies that are going on
in this campaign that's going on.
The first is
to clear this epidemic of men murdering women as a national emergency
so that it gets funding and attention and an expedition of solutions.
The next one is
changing the media regulation on publishing images of victims
because the media have been publishing these faces of the victims
right after attacks
and this is very traumatic for families and without families consent.
Next one is mandatory victim blaming prevention training,
um, for like first responders, um,
because most of them aren't actually trained in how to um,
properly deal with a situation and then they can reinforce the trauma.
It's often called secondary victimization
before is alternative reporting options and um,
domestic violence specialist in the court system.
This is because um, so many women don't report
and they don't report because there are huge barriers to reporting
including mistrust of authority,
the perception is too difficult,
which it is, it's re traumatizing.
They have internalized, um,
blame and shame and I could go on
but there's heaps of really valid and legitimate reasons why
a lot of different women and different groups don't report
and this is all aiming to address that so that we have actual justice,
um, and better data and The fifth one is better funding.
Fund it, fund,
fund it. It's never been funded.
It's never been funded properly.
Male behaviour change has never been funded properly.
Services have never been funded properly.
Research has never been funded properly.
So the idea is to fund it.
That's it. On an individual level,
if you are a man, um,
some things you can do include,
you know, not killing women,
um, not harassing women,
not assaulting women, not coercing women,
not gaslighting women, going to therapy,
doing the work, becoming an ally,
calling out your male friends,
calling out a sexist language,
not expecting, um,
your wife or women in your life to do all of the household labour,
not really adhering to outdated and traditional gender norms
because those are the things that prop up violence against women.
I hope that helps.